Okay.
In this video we'll discuss the
different type of output layer,
which is going to be more efficient to
use in the context of language modeling.
Uh, and we will call that out type of
output layer, a hierarchical output layer.
So we've seen a previous video how to
define the neural network language model,
which is essentially a neural net
that takes as input all of the word
representations of the words in
some given conditioning context.
And then we concatenate
those representation and
feed that to regular neural
network where at the output
we get a softmax layer,
which will define the and give us the
probability of observing each possible
word in our vocabulary
following our context.
Now one problem with this approach is
that the softmax layer here is actually
really,
really big.
If we have say a 250,000
words in our vocabulary,
that it means that this layer
has to 250,000 different units,
one for each possible word.
And when performing the Softmax,
we does have to compute
all the reactivation.
So these 250,000 activations and then
we have to perform the softmax known in
the charity.
So that's going to be very expensive
to do if we have to do this for every
training example,
every example of context and the
word that follows it in the text.
So what we'll talk about here is
a way of getting a much better,
much more efficient, uh, have
a defining a distribution.
The distribution offered the next
word, given the previous word, uh,
which in practice is very efficient
and gives us good performance as well.
Okay.
The main idea is to, instead of modeling
the probability of the next word,
using a flat layer,
we use a hierarchical layer where our
wheel decompose their probability of
observing the word into a
sequence of probabilities,
which corresponds to choices
as to uh, to which group, uh,
does the next word is more likely
to, to belong, to, to organize.
These groups will actually take
all of the words in our vocabulary.
And let's work with an example
to make this more concrete.
So imagine we have eight words in
our vocabulary and the old fee work.
Now we will do is that will place all
of these words into a treat and sensei
complete tree like here, uh, which is uh,
which is balanced and
essentially the probability of a,
of a given word following the context
is going to be given by the probability
that from the route we would actually
follow the path to the word cat in the
tree. That is, we would go left
here, right here and then right here,
so left at the note labeled one,
right that the node label too.
And then right at the node level five.
So if we model probabilities this way,
we noticed that we actually only need
the probabilities for these three nodes
and we don't need the probabilities
for say the nodes here or this note.
So if we look at the probability
of one specific word,
then actually computing
probabilities is going to be a,
it's going to be a,
I have a computational burden proportional
to the depth of the word in the tree.
And if we have a balanced tree
is going to be logarithmic.
So it's going to be much more efficient
to compute one specific probability.
So more specifically what
we'll do is that we will, uh,
essentially have all of
these nodes in the tree,
correspond to a sigmoidal. Uh, I'll
put you in, it's in the neural nets,
will have connections
from the hidden layer.
So imagine we had this context
and then from this context,
the neural net would extract the word
representations, concatenate them,
and compute the hidden
layer off the neural net.
So that's what this corresponds to here.
And now this hidden layer,
we'll connect it to all of the nodes in
the internal notes in our trees and not
the leaf nodes, which aren't the
words, but the internal notes.
We'll connect them with the matrix of
parameters, which I'm calling v here.
And so like I said before,
now say we take this example where we
want the probability that cat would follow
the context,
which is made up the word that dog.
And that in this case,
all I need is really the probability of,
uh,
taking the right decision,
the right, uh, branches, uh,
at each of the internal
notes, one, two, and five.
So at one specifically I want the
probability of branching left.
And then at two I want the probability
of branching, right? And then five,
the probability of a branch,
Shane, uh, right. So this,
uh, this shouldn't be three. They
should be, they should be fine.
And so, uh, no,
what we need is for the neural net to
output us this probability to provide us a
model for these probabilities of,
of branching.
So like I said,
we could use sigmoidal units and then,
uh,
so essentially for this note,
we would take the product of the row
in Matrix v that corresponds to the
parameters of this note here,
when multiply that by the hidden
layer and then with applied a sigmoid.
And then we could interpret this as
the probability of say a branching,
a right, it could be branching
left, it doesn't matter.
This is an arbitrary choice.
As long as we're consistent with the
way we interpret the probabilities.
So for this example,
we're assuming that taking v multiply by
the hidden layer and applying to sigma,
it gives us the probability of
branching right at a given a note.
So it means that while
initially the probability of
cat of reaching cap would be
to, they're probably the brunching
right? A left then, right then, right
then if I want to use my
model to validate that,
probably I'll convert the probability of
branching as one minus the probability
of branching. Right? And then
like I said before, I'll, uh,
use my model to compute these
probabilities and they're
going to be computed as
the hidden layer multiplied by the
associated row in my matrix of connections
feet. So we see here that will be taking
the first row for the first note here,
taking the second row for the second
node here and in the fifth row for the
fifth, a node here in my, in my tree.
And we were doing the same thing
for the [inaudible], the first bias.
Second bias if fifth
bias in my bias vector B.
So by taking the product of all of this,
then that would give me the
probability of reaching cap.
And I've been able to compute
it in this model using only, uh,
uh,
using computation that scale,
not linearly in the number
of words in my vocabulary,
but logarithmically and that's because
I'm using a balanced tree where the depth
of the tree is, uh, uh, in
the order of the logarithm of,
uh, the number of words in the
vocabulary. Okay. So that's the article.
That's the general idea for
the article output layer. Uh,
that is very useful for, uh, in
the neural network language model.
So now how do we actually define
this? This tree, this word Harkey, uh,
that organizes the words and two
different leaves of a, of a treat.
Uh, the simplest thing to do probably
is to just generate this trees randomly.
So we'd read, we'd a essentially
generate a complete tree,
so make it balanced so that at least
the computations and the tree is
logarithmic. And, um, uh,
and then we just assigned the leaves of
that tree randomly, two different words.
So we take each word and we assigned
randomly to a different leaf in industry.
Uh, this is likely to be suboptimal for
language modeling. It, it actually is.
We get a worse performance
by doing this then, uh,
by using the softmax layer. Uh,
that being said, it's, it's,
it's not an entirely terrible, so,
um, uh, it's, uh, it against it.
It'll give a decent results and other
approaches to actually use something good
stick resources, say a we're net,
which is, uh, uh, essentially a,
a data structure. Four words were
the words organized in some tree.
And, uh, essentially the, uh, words
that are semantically related, uh,
share certain sensors are,
are closer in, in that tree.
So I won't go into detail
of how we're networks.
You can look at this paper for how in
particular you can use where net to derive
a tree for organizing all the
words and the, uh, into a tree.
But in this paper,
they actually reported really good speed
ups that you'd expect from using a,
a tree,
and they only saw a slight decrease in
performance compared to using a softmax
layer. Uh, and then
finally, more recently, uh,
in this paper by me and Hinton,
uh,
a learning approach and machine learning
approach for trying to derive what this
word Harkey should be, uh, was proposed.
It was based on a recursive
partitioning strategy. Uh,
so the way they would actually learn
the trees that they would first learn
irregular model. So a,
if I wanted that models,
if you trained it with a softmax layer,
that would be slow.
So perhaps you could use instead a a
random tree and train a first model.
Uh,
that model will have trained some word
representations and then we'll try to use
these word representations in order
to infer what the tree should be.
And the way we'll do that,
this,
that we'll use some
hierarchical clustering
approach where first weed at the
root note of our tree,
that would correspond to a cluster
which contains all of the words, uh, in,
uh,
in our vocabulary.
And then I'd use the word representations
a and run the a clustering algorithm
where I would extract all the
two clusters. So for instance,
my clustering algorithm could
identify that this forms a cluster.
And this forms and other cluster.
Uh,
and then I would recursively continue
doing these binary clusterings,
uh, but over the partitioning is that
I discovered that the previous stage.
So in this case I would rerun and
other clustering algorithm, uh,
within this Gloucester and then
within also discussed or separately.
So maybe I'd get these two clusters here
and then here I'd get these two other
clusters. And then I continue like
this until in, uh, my clusters,
our only have at most a two words.
Then for cluster,
it has two words in it.
Then that defines the two leaves for
that particular part of the tree and to
extract the tree. Then I just go from
the general clusters or this one here.
That would be the leaf. Uh,
sorry, the root of the tree,
it's two leaves would be this
cluster and this cluster. And then,
so for this cluster it's two leaves
would be this cluster and this cluster.
So all of the words here would be
saying on the left, uh, part of, uh,
that, uh, that tree accorded corresponding
to that cluster here. And this would,
these two words would be on the right.
And then I kicked, did you like this?
So this node in the tree would have one
of its a leaf be this node here and in
another leaf would be an internal node
of crisp corresponding to that cluster,
which has two leaves,
which are these two words here and so
on for the other part of the treat.
So we see that from this, we can extract,
uh, our Harkey, uh, for the words,
and then we could use that
Harkey, uh, for prediction.
And so the advantage of doing this is
that if we have good word representations
that were pretrained using a random
tree or some other, uh, procedure,
then this tree will more directly reflect
the similarity between these words
putting clothes together and the
tree words to have close a word
representations.
And then I could retrain a new model,
a new neural network language model
that uses this tree now instead of c of
random tree in order to perform a
neural network language modeling.
So for more details,
I encourage you to look at this paper,
but they show that they get similar kind
of speed ups you would get with other
types of trees and uh, uh, but
without a performance decrease.
So that's very encouraging. Uh,
it's a, it's a very good result.
And before I end,
I just want to say that this hardcore
output layer is useful where for given
contexts, we want to evaluate
the probability of just
one word or a few words.
If we actually wanted the full
distribution over all the words, uh,
we wouldn't gain anything because we
would still need to get to the probability
of branching left and right for every
node within the tree and the number of
nodes,
the total number of internal nodes in
the tree is going to be linear in the
number of words.
Uh,
and so we won't actually have gained
anything if far giving context.
We have to compute the probability of
all the words. So it's really when for,
since we were training,
we know what is the next word.
Then we only need to evaluate the
probability of that next word.
Then in this case, we get
a speed up. But otherwise,
if we need the full distribution,
then, uh, we don't sell it.
Get a speed up in that case,
and we'll still scale linearly in the
number of words in the vocabulary.
All right, so that's it about
how I call output layer.
And now most modern no network language
models use some sort of hierarchical
output layer.
I've described the binary layer where
at every node you make a binary decision
benching left and right.
You could have other versions of that
where you would actually branch mall
multi-way not just left and
right. Uh, but in general,
the idea is that by doing
a hierarchical approach,
we can get good speed ups in and
be able to apply neural nets, uh,
for language modeling
unfair logical capillaries.